ich habe es gerade schon gesagt fahren
wir bald alle mit dem Fahrrad da wo das
plötzlich ganz schnell hier in dieser
lebhaften Runde ja der rot rot grüne
Senat der hat jetzt zumindest soweit
kommen lassen dass ab Januar die
Fahrräder auf den autoparkplätzen parken
dürfen und das umsonst die
autofahrerseite zwei manchmal drei
manchmal 4 € und dort ein paar Stunden
zu stehen jetzt kann da in Zukunft ein
Radl stehen was das alles mit Berlin mit
der Hauptstadt machen könnte da hat
Sebastian mein Kollege große Befürchtung
also unglaublich das Berlins mobilitäts
Senatorin wie sie sich an den Bettina
Jahres eine grüne selbstverständlich was
sie da macht sie will dass Menschen ja
ihr Fahrrad auf dem Auto Parkplatz
abstellen warum damit natürlich die
Autoparkplätze wieder mal blockiert sind
damit noch mehr Parkplätze verschwinden
da wird ein Kulturkampf gegen das Auto
jetzt quasi zum Straßenkampf gemacht da
werden Menschen aber den
Verkehrsteilnehmer gegeneinander
aufgebracht dieser Senat schafft ihr
Probleme die sonst eigentlich gar nicht
da sind und eigentlich Berliner
aufeinander das darf nicht sein ich frag
mich mal Frau jarasch wie ist denn das
was sagen sie denn zum Beispiel der
Krankenschwester die abends vom
Schichtdienst kommt und die einfach nur
noch nach Hause und ins Bett will die
dann ewig irgendwie suchen muss nach
einem Parkplatz ja denn das sind die
Menschen wir normal Bürger die eben
nicht irgendwie ein tieferagen Platz
haben oder so die das Geld nicht haben
vor Jahren nämlich das muss man mal
sagen lässt sich selbst im 7er BMW durch
diese Stadt kutschieren deswegen sage
ich dieser Vorschlag man kann sich schon
mal darauf einstellen das geht ab Januar
das muss gestoppt werden das Wahnsinn
er stellte nehmen wir mal an sie sind
unterwegs mit ihrem Auto vielleicht ein
größeres ein SUV oder sowas und wollen
Parkplatz und dann steht ein kleines
Klapprad was machen sie damit reagieren
nicht persönlich fahren weil ich ja in
Berlin wohne und vor dem Hintergrund
weiß dass wir jetzt schon abläuft also
bei dem Hintergrund mache ich das nicht
mit der U-Bahn in die Stadt ich muss
dazu sagen ich nehme als meistens äh
sharing weil sie mich persönlich fragen
machen ja das stimmt aber das ist
manchmal sind auch sehr kompakte
Fahrzeuge leichter ich glaube der Punkt
ist ein bisschen was anderes ich glaube
die Frage ist halt immer wenn wir mehr
öffentliche Nahverkehr wollen dann
würden wir mal vergleichen wo läuft
eigentlich gut ja jetzt die Sachen die
Welt und ich muss einfach sagen also
Japan sind Japan fahren ein Traum
picobello sauber alles ordentlich wir
müssen gar nicht so weit weggehen auch
wenn sie nach Basel gehen werde dann
öffentliche Nahverkehr verbessern Hotel
gegen kriegen sie automatisch ein
Fahrscheine können sie öffentlich
Nahverkehr nutzen aber alles auch in
Deutschland gibt es besser ist Berlin
ist es vielleicht nicht gerade das muss
dabei Beispiele so und natürlich hat man
sagen naja gut anstatt immer quasi was
ist was jetzt voll wenn der öffentlichen
Nahverkehr nicht attraktiv ist macht man
die attraktive wirklich unattraktiv ich
persönlich würde sagen lasst uns doch
den wirklich Nahverkehr Sorte tief
machen dass man freiwillig den nimmt und
macht das andere nicht unattraktiv und
das ist übrigens was in Deutschland
oftmals gerne gemacht wird dass man im
Prinzip teilweise schon den zweiten
Schritt nach vor den ersten mir wäre es
lieber man würde eben dafür sorgen dass
der öffentliche Nahverkehr sauber und
sicher ist und dass wenn auch mal was
passiert dass das irgendwie nicht erst
morgen später irgendwann mal dieses
Video veröffentlicht wird sondern früher
auch ein Großbritannien London wenn sie
London sind gibt's auch einen sicheren
öffentlichen Raum aufgrund der
Videoüberwachung also ich finde das
müssen wir halt machen also insofern ist
es einfach ein falscher Ansatz ich will
Hals ist ja die ideologisch aus meiner
Sicht also ich finde die
Grundbedürfnisse der Menschen müssen für
staatlich werden also wie zum Beispiel
die ganzen Krankenhäuser die ganzen
Stadtwerke die ganzen Infrastrukturen
der der der Busse ich bin selber im
Stadtrat drinne dann werden die Sachen
ausgeschrieben wo keiner nachher
bezahlen kann
hier bei uns in Berlin wie finden sie
das jetzt am Aktivisten auch gesagt wir
kaufen jetzt alle Gebrauchtfahrräder auf
und dann werden die einfach schön
geparkt damit es dort die Autos keinen
Platz mehr haben ein Fahrzeug ein
Q8 und habe aber einen neuen Fuhrpark wo
ich nur Smart habe das sehen Sie hier
zum Beispiel von meiner Seite
nur für die Stadt da habe ich drei vier
Fahrzeugen leute kauft euch kleinere
Autos
vorsichtig sein dass immer die Lösung
die Lösung ist erstens ist es keine
Lösung die anderen zu provozieren die
Fahrräder haben und sagen ich suche mal
die Autofahrer zeigen wo es lang geht
umgekehrt aber auch wollen wir hier
Gewalt haben ich ich sehe das wirklich
man muss ein bisschen an meiner
an die Themen dran gehen wo finden wir
Lösung für alle beide Seiten alle beide
Seiten müssen sich wiederfinden so ist
es wenigstens in der Wirtschaft wenn ich
verhandeln mit dem Arbeitgeber muss ich
eine Lösung finden wo der Arbeitgeber
sagt damit kann ich leben und umgekehrt
wo die Arbeitnehmer und so müssen wir
mit den Radfahrer und mit den
Autofahrern eine Lösung finden aber es
kann nicht sein dass einseitig die
einfach sagen ich nehme die Gewalt in
Anspruch also ich tue einfach ein
Fahrrad hinstellen und wenn Sie das
Fahrrad wegnimmst dann werde ich
aggressiv ich will einfach das mal und
da sage ich da müssen die Politiker
einschalten und nicht sagen das lasse
ich mal laufen und wenn es dann schief
läuft so machen sie es ja leider
öfters dann sagen sie oh wie kann ich
die Leute bestrafen in Wahrheit ist es
ja tatsächlich so also was Frau Jahre
will ist das ist Menschen die eben kein
Tiefgaragenplatz haben oder sowas
unmöglich ist als Privathaushalt
überhaupt noch ein Auto zu haben weil
kein Platz mehr das ist abzustellen
deswegen genau Bescheid dann wie alles
andere in Berlin gescheitert ist ich
meine die Regierung hat er schon track
record ich meine Friedrichstraße ist das
ist eine Straße wurde komplett gesperrt
für den Autoverkehr da wurden
umfangreiche Baumaßnahmen ergriffen
wurde viel Geld verschwendet und hat das
Gericht gesagt aber leider nicht richtig
wirksam das heißt wurde alles wieder
zurück gemacht und sie Geschäft sind
noch nicht ganz froh dass überhaupt
das war schönes Beispiel oder
mietendeckel anders
glauben
aber der Punkt ist einfach der ist sie
sie hört ja auch sagen wir schaffen alle
Parkplätze ab nein sie machen jetzt im
Prinzip machen sie die Aktivisten zu
ihren Handlangern um das durchzusetzen
und das führt zu einer gemeinsamen
wahnsinnigen Polarisierung noch eine
starke Gesellschaft und dann gucken
natürlich dazu führen dass irgendwann
mal Perspektive stand doch andere
Parteien antreten wird anderen
Programmen und das ist dann
irgendwann die Demokratie bestehen
bleibt wird es dann irgendwann da eine
Gegenreaktion gehen selbst in Berlin das
kann aber noch 10 Jahre dauern und das
andere Finanzausgleich so großzügig
fließen
sie dann einfach rum wenn ein Fahrrad
steht dann sich ja gut okay jetzt sind
die Parkplätze auch fürs Fahrrad die
sind dahinter ist so sagt dass man die
Bürgersteige frei machen will würden sie
dann sagen ja gut verstehe ich jetzt
suche ich noch eine halbe Stunde also
zum verkleblichen Frankfurt da haben wir
das nicht ich finde auch der Ansatz ist
vollkommen richtig in der Kritik ich
glaube dass das ideologisch ist und
Ideologie schadet immer weil das Wetter
zu führen dass zwei Verkehrsteilnehmer
die Radfahrer und die Autofahrer noch
mehr gegeneinander ausgespielt werden
das ist schlecht
prinzipiell ist es so dass wir natürlich
gerade Großstädte verkehrspolitisch
komplett neu denken müssen das ist
einfach so dass das Setzen aus den 70er
Jahren übrig geblieben setzen pur aufs
Auto in Großstädten nicht mehr
funktioniert das weiß auch jeder da
brauchen wir auch gerne drumherum reden
also müssen wir schauen und da stimme
ich ihn zu 100% zu der öffentliche
Nahverkehr muss wesentlich besser
gemacht werden wir sehen in Frankfurt da
sehr stark ja also das funktioniert in
Frankfurt ganz gut aber wir haben in
Frankfurt auch Ideologien wo Straßen
zugemacht werden die überhaupt keinen
Sinn machen wo es wirklich nur um die
Gänge live von Autofahren also
ehrlicherweise zum Training und die
möchte ich endlich mal sehen
ehrlicherweise muss man sagen ich kann
eine empirische Forschung an mir selbst
gemacht an und ich bin ein absoluter
Autofahrer ich bin vor drei Jahren noch
morgens zum Bäcker gefahren mit dem Auto
und habe die Brötchen geholt also der
Prototyp eines wirklichen
umweltschädlings gewesen und habe aber
durch diese Repressionen die Frankfurt
natürlich auch gezielt verteilt gelernt
mit öffentlichen Verkehrsmitteln zu
fahren und mit Fahrrad so und jetzt sind
wir beim entscheidenden Punkt ich sage
selbstkritisch zu mir ohne dass man mir
permanent auf die Füße getreten wäre
hätte es nicht gemacht ich finde aber
trotzdem das Berliner Beispiel furchtbar
und ganz schlecht und glaube dass das
kontraproduktiv aber würden Sie Ihr Auto
aufgeben wenn sie so lange aber ich
merke jetzt schon ich habe früher eine
Laufleistung gehabt von 25 30.000 km im
Jahr ich bin im Moment bei 8 bis 10.000
also man merkt sehr deutlich dort wo es
einen guten öffentlichen Nahverkehr gibt
ist man bereit auch umzusteigen es gibt
für mich ich wohne direkt an der U-Bahn
es gibt 0,0 Grund für mich in die Stadt
rein zu fahren mit dem Auto weil das nur
Schwierigkeiten macht und jetzt sind wir
bei fliegen halt lieber hin und her ne
sie sind von Mallorca gekommen
aber das immer doch beim entscheidenden
Punkt und dann müssen wir uns doch
ehrlich mal ich fahre doch jetzt zum
Beispiel weniger weil man mich gegängelt
hat weil man mir gesagt hat
aber wir müssen doch trotzdem ehrlich
sein wir müssen doch für die für die
Großstädte ein neues Verkehrskonzept
haben und das zumindest mal neu denken
über Berlin weil ich mich da viel zu
wenig ausgehen im übrigen
gesagt haben ich war vor vier Wochen in
New York weil das ist ja das Land der
unbegrenzten Möglichkeit da empfehle ich
Ihnen keine U-Bahn zu fahren ja ich
musste in der U-Bahn Station ein Cappy
aufziehen weil es von oben rein geregnet
hat also zum Thema
überzeugen sollten die Bürger Gängelei
führt zu Aggression absolute nee weil du
gerade gesagt ich wurde ein bisschen
mehr die Menschen überzeugen diesen Mut
muss man haben diese Kraft diesmal haben
aber ich sehe kein Politiker jetzt
Leiter die jetzt in Berlin sagen hallo
Leute ich tue mal meine meine
Überzeugung mal erklären
ein bisschen Druck ja das ist in Ordnung